Mind your Decisions, I'm Presh Talwalkar.
An equilateral triangle is inscribed in a unit square.
What is the area of the equilateral triangle?
Pause the video if you'd like to give this problem a try, and when you're ready. keep watching to learn how to solve this problem.
(music)
So, how can we solve this problem?
Let's write s for the length of the equilateral triangle side.
The square has a side length of 1. Now, in this right triangle, suppose
the other leg is equal to x. By the Gogu theorem, s^2 = 1^2 + x^2.
Now, consider the following right triangle. Its hypotenuse is also equal to s, and one of its legs is equal to 1.
Therefore, its other leg must also be equal to x.
Finally, we have one more triangle.
It must have legs of 1-x, because the entire length of the square side is equal to 1.
We therefore have s^2 = (1-x)^2 + (1-x)^2.
We'll simplify this a little bit, and now we have two equations.
We'll consider this system of equations. We'll subtract the second equation from the first,
and the s^2 terms will cancel out.
We then get an equation in one variable x. We can routinely solve this, and we get a quadratic equation.
We use the quadratic formula, and then we simplify to get two possibilities:
x = 2-√3 and x = 2+√3.
Now, recall that x < side of the square, so 0<x<1.
Therefore, we reject 2+√3,and we accept 2-√3.
Once we have the value of x, we can go ahead and solve for s^2,
and then, remember we're trying to solve for the area of the equilateral triangle, which is equal to (s^2*√3)/4.
We simplify this, and we get 2√3 - 3, which is approximately
0.464, and that's our answer.
Thanks for making Mind your Decisions one of the best channels on YouTube. As always thanks for watching, and thanks for your support.